hello and welcome to this video playing
the super mr. so to Morocco I'll
Portugal I'm sorry is it is pretty
clearly Portugal okay um I play I played
this a plane out of 60 oops didn't hell
no not the Queen please that's the
interesting sideline now of their of the
Italian game that is actually quite
interesting for why to play not that
white is much better or anything but it
leads to fresh position something that
is not as well explored the f5 move is
an interesting idea that black can go
for you and Dargo try that I'm not sure
if this is played in this particular
position but it is something that can be
played in this position type making it
more difficult for white to get rid of
that e4 night now you you don't want to
take it if the f porn is able to capture
yeah still white should probably play
some move it's certainly not like his
worse yeah what is my next plan down
yeah maybe just develop with Bush should
be 69 on c6 is an interesting piece that
it put some pressure on deform yes this
one yeah I think f4 is a probably that's
to lose young therefore I think 94 I can
take with the deep on that should be
okay
Oh interesting yeah he's taking away
some pressure now a force more
interesting asking white where he's
going orange I can take only 3 a.m. that
is not totally I would have the picture
and then capture on f2 the only bad
thing is that my queen is all the way in
the corner so probably not a great idea
so again capturing that's very
simplifying way to do it hmm and I'll
taking only three however makes quite
some sense check either allows me to
allow soon that I keep this pawn or
gives the exchange I mean both doesn't
look terribly convincing now also there
is a question there what about can I
cannot sacrifice this rook and just go
for the attack now with Bishop g4 while
something like that that pin is pretty
nasty I wonder if it's an idea simply to
give up the give up the rook but this
comes with tempo so i can i can static
it and still play Bishop g4 I just
wonder if I go Bishop g4 now what what
is idea especially them 3 2 d 3 maybe
more okay I'll do that
yeah that was big yeah it looks like I
mean how can you play that instantly
anyway who gave three isn't that killing
here I just got to check on d5 haha it's
very fortunate for white
ok
hmm somehow hard to believe that there's
no direct win in this position but maybe
it isn't I don't see a direct win okay
this is really not what I wanted but if
I think for for you longer you might be
in this old-timer that would be a real
shame after how this game went
okay Ruby one had an idea I should have
figured that idea what it wasn't exactly
rocket science
oh my goodness what if what what a
nonsensical way of playing how did I do
that and really happy that he is also
probably playing some yeah non optimal I
came time morning rise checking me down
unbelievable game
you
46 was about 56 I know the whole thing's
now rather unclear to me
takes it f once mate so lets you came
how to do that here
I have no time here yeah he's gotten
this two pawns
yes kind of game when you look at it up
to it with an engine you feel like the
biggest idiot ever yeah because you
probably sport like a plus 10 plus 20 or
so check no the position is ok again
really ok what check check check
check check hey it's doing everything to
lose this game but yeah probably
timewise j so why attack it fits and
intimated oh my goodness have a look at
the most luckiest guy over here mr.
super mr. i can't even win no time for
me now for go anywhere else or king be
one or whatever but again what i came i
do adam of course the game should never
ever reach this stage because this this
game this move is so atrocious Bishop
takes his six that it just it just it
just lose this outright if I'm not a
total idiot like I am I came giantess
this and if I just give this rook on a
that's probably over already Queenie
eight is winning flat hair okay with the
way it went it must also be a total win
yeah I queen bee three year and it's
amazing I wanted to I wanted to take
care of course this this this but he's
got to check this is the thing oops i am
doing stuff ian an unlikely to be 55 was
winning off both but he played then the
only way that I'm still winning now and
I really wonder how much of an advantage
it was must must have been enormous okay
Bishop f5 is also easy winning yeah yeah
I didn't see anything and he got all
those pawns check and now he was busy
check check completely miss playing that
Queen ending to a loss check of course
I'm winning with the youporn now and I
actually didn't do that didn't do that
badly check I just have to run chan
just have to be Evan have no time I just
have to go somewhere here and it's over
it's just so on check and I can also
just take this I mean I can just take
the Queen this is unbelievable yeah this
is the kind of game that keeps me from
getting to 2500 the completely
completely mindless idiotic game where
I'm making 10 double ? moose way really
wonder if I should have my brain checked
and its cost us this kind of game costs
like 20 points yeah or something like
that yeah and it's impossible to lose I
mean you already have to play like a
complete brain dead person 28 points is
that game yeah and it's so easy to win I
mean I'm not talking just about that but
also earlier this is this is the reason
why I'm not getting getting higher to
that those idiotic losses that are
completely inexplicable in a way okay